[Música]
y llegó el momento a hablar de salud
aquí en directo américa de france 24 ya
está conmigo en el estudio más romeros a
la mara bienvenida ya estamos a mitad de
semana y vamos a hablar de la muerte y
el debate que hay alrededor de la
medicalización en estas etapas finales
de la vida explíquenos entonces de qué
se trata esto más pues al final cómo nos
morimos como vivimos estas últimas
etapas siempre va a ser uno de los
debates que vamos a tener yo creo que
como sociedad y precisamente por eso hay
una comisión interdisciplinar de muchos
expertos aquí publicó un artículo en the
lancet criticando estas sobre
medicalización una medicalización
excesiva es decir que la muerte suceda
en entornos exclusivamente hospitalarios
medicalizados con asistentes de salud
pero por ejemplo no pensando pues en lo
que sucede con los familiares o como
proceso vital una vez pues se termina
nuestras vidas es decir por ejemplo
priorizar mantener con vida a los
pacientes antes que priorizar pues
acompañarlos en estas últimas etapas las
cifras nos muestran algo que tiene mucho
que ver con esto por ejemplo entre el
2000 y el 2009 la esperanza de vida
global aumentó de los 66 ocho años hasta
los setenta y 34 años esto es un aumento
de más de seis años es una buena noticia
en muchos aspectos estamos estamos
seguro es decir no discutimos de eso
pero no podemos dejar de lado también
que los años con condiciones
discapacitantes y limitantes para la
vida también aumentaron de 86 a 10 años
eso significa que hubo 10 años en los
que las personas de media pues no podían
vivir con la mitad de la misma manera
que antes por otro lado esta misma
comisión que publicaba este artículo
recuerda que en otros lugares del mundo
que no son este norte global hay
millones y millones de personas que
mueren en sufrimiento porque no tienen
un acceso a los cuidados paliativos que
si se tienen muchos países pues
occidentales o en países de ingresos
altos
al final partimos también y entramos en
un debate algo filosófico pero que
afecta mucho en nuestra salud raúl y es
que esta ciencia o la medicina es algo
que sé que puede ayudarnos a derrotar la
muerte como sobre algo que tenemos que
ganar en vez de que sea algo que nos
acompañe en la vida o que nos acompañe
también en estas últimas etapas de la
muerte y que cuando nos acercamos al
final de nuestras de nuestras vidas y no
debemos olvidar
en tu mucho también durante la pandemia
recordemos tantos millones de personas
que murieron lejos de sus seres queridos
por ejemplo así es más bueno seguimos en
español porque familiares y
organizaciones denuncian las muertes de
miles de ancianos en residencias durante
la pandemia de hecho es un ejemplo
bastante adecuado para hablar de lo que
estábamos diciendo justo ahora no un
montón miles de personas que en españa
no sólo en españa- también en reino
unido- en eeuu murieron en estas
residencias para adultos mayores
totalmente incomunicados de sus
familiares sobre todo durante la primera
ola de covite 19 ahora amnistía
internacional y varios familiares de
estas víctimas denuncian lo que ha
sucedido escuchemos lo
tenemos una señora que murió de hambre o
sea se murió de hambre como no sabía
comer y nadie le daba pues se murió de
hambre hay gente que estaba muy bien
hablando con su hija a los tres de la
tarde a las siete de la tarde falleció
no sabemos cómo murió o sea nosotros
jamás volveremos a ser las personas que
éramos porque tenemos que vivir con eso
y quieren cubrir una oscuridad sobre lo
que ocurrió quieren pasar página'
quieren que nos olvidemos todos de que
aquello ha sido una tragedia de unas
dimensiones extraordinarias y sin
embargo a nosotros no nos quieren
escuchar
la principal denuncia de estos grupos es
que el gobierno español no está
investigando estas muertes estas
cantidades de muertes y negligencias
también que sucedieron ahí por ejemplo
una de las familiares dice que había en
la residencia donde vivía su madre solo
una persona que cuidara a más de 20
personas 100% dependientes no preocupa
esta impunidad preocupa el
desconocimiento sobre las últimas horas
de la vida de muchísimos familiares de
gente en españa hay aproximadamente unas
30 mil muertes que sucedieron en esa
primera ola en las residencias pero
luego también hubo muchos por descuidos
por negligencias heridas que se infectan
normal desnutrición incluso entonces
pues estamos hablando de que no se están
investigando estas situaciones y también
pues el efecto que ha tenido de esto
sobre la salud mental de todas nuestras
sociedades no la pandemia en general así
es marc y por supuesto vamos a terminar
entonces hablando de los trabajadores de
la salud y como la panda miento se ha
afectado su bienestar mental y emocional
marc si no no hay duda que esta pandemia
nos ha dejado heridas a todos pero
principalmente también a estos
trabajadores de la salud que vivieron en
la pandemia desde el momento cero no por
un lado por el riesgo de contagio
obviamente pero también por el golpe
emocional que supone enfrentarse a esta
crisis de salud pública desde california
recientemente nos llegaban estos
testimonios
creo que los últimos dos años han sido
los peores años de muchas de nuestras
vidas no sé si el público entiende lo
que todavía vemos si vivimos
fuimos héroes durante que un mes
y no nos gustó ser héroes solo estábamos
haciendo nuestro trabajo
estamos todos quemados a distintos
niveles algunos de nosotros nos hemos
apartado de la enfermería hospitalaria
otros han cambiado completamente de
departamento
todos hemos atravesado nuestra montaña
rusa emocional
son testimonios bien duros raúl sin
lugar a dudas y de hecho en muchas
cifras que también apoyan estas
declaraciones que llegaban desde
hospital de california según un informe
de mental health america vemos que por
ejemplo 86% de los trabajadores de la
salud llegaron con ansiedad 76% decían
que estaban exhaustos la inmensa mayoría
reportó por ejemplo estrés y todo esto
con muchos impactos también sobre la
salud física de estos trabajadores el
70% son son casi tres cuartos de los
encuestados decían que tenían problemas
para dormir más de la mitad sintió
cambios de apetito no que dan lugar a
duda raúl de que todos salimos con
dolores de esta pandemia que vamos a
tener que sanar
así es más pues bueno muchísimas gracias
por toda la información en este espacio
de salud del día de hoy de directo
américa nos vemos mañana con más y por
ahora voy a pasar a nuestro segundo
invitado del día